in a previous video Mike was talking
about how a face idea probably worked he
was telling us that this probably based
on the Internet's
exactly how this network works isn't
clear even to the people we'll try and
find it
in this video I'm gonna be talking about
fingerprint recognition as an
alternative to do authentication systems
so we've been using for a while
fingerprint sensor so maybe in on your
phone you have one on your tablet or
even on your laptops and maybe you're
wondering is that also based on neural
networks and deep learning stuff well it
could be and not saying otherwise but
it's actually not normally because you
don't need that you don't need to learn
anything you basically need to make able
to distinguish if this fingerprint
impression is the same as the one being
is before so basically what we're gonna
be doing first is trying to extract
meaningful features from your fingertip
and trying to characterize your
fingerprint and then whenever you want
to identify yourself you need to double
check if these are the same what we call
me notion points so let's have a look on
the iPad two two fingerprints oh it did
work and so here we have two
fingerprints and so here I have a
question for you and do you think these
two are from the same person yes or no
this is sort of I'm gonna call it around
a bit here and around a bit on that one
and then there's kind of a triangle a
bit on that one so they look similar I
think I'd have to cut one out maybe I'd
be able to work a family exactly so
actually they do belong to the same
person it's a good job you detected that
correctly but you need to be more
confident next time otherwise how do you
unlock your phone and so so the first
process we do is call feature extraction
and what you need to do first and most
algorithms will do well trying to
identify the region of interest so
basically that means you're gonna try to
cut this now because you don't need it
right and as you can see there are two
impressions of exactly the same finger
and they do look is slightly different
because it that depends on where you put
your finger on the sensor and also it's
all about the pressure
and you use when you are unlocking your
phone for example so that will change
slightly the picture so no two
impressions of the same fingerprint will
look alike so then sit your instruction
and there are so many different features
you can extract from here many of them
call level one are all about
orientations what are those well you see
here the orientation of these
fingerprints years like that and it goes
in this direction let's say so this
would we call orientations there are two
singular points which are very
distinctive in a fingerprint and one of
them is the court if you look here on
the left this round the beta you notice
it's just a look right so this would
like own and identify us the core of the
fingerprint and you also actually notice
this very special bit here that looks
like a delta on here so these two are
the two most important characteristic
for a fingerprint are they the ones that
we actually use for recognition not
quite it depends for classification yes
but when you're trying to do the
matching they are important but they are
not the only ones fight swimming here
you will see those ridges on here so for
example you see that this one actually
ended over here so what we are gonna be
doing is typically you're gonna have
this coordinate annotate it and then you
have kind of an arrow here say well this
is the direction in which I found that
minutiae points so that's how they call
it and you also will see nice stuff like
this before occasion on here so all of
the sudden the rich did something funny
just like that so this is a very special
point so typically this will be
annotated and saying well this is the
point it changes direction exactly in
that point so if you continue you will
see plenty of those on here here is just
a man of the rich so you can do that and
get plenty of that how do you do that
will you just address directly the
picture well not quite because if you
try you're going to detect also minutiae
points here on the outside of the image
so the first thing is to try to cut out
anything is not from the fingerprint
then there will be a thinning process in
which he's in somehow kind of
segmentation kind of techniques you will
actually try to enhance those lines
those black lines here on your
fingerprint something that's also this
thing test is you really swim in here
you will see some pores within the range
of your fingerprint so they are quite
distinctive but you require a very high
resolution image to detect those so
that's why they are not normally used
for fingerprint matching because you
need a very high quality sensor so
they're gonna be based basically on when
they collide two ridges when they are
ending when they just change so these
are the points that you want to get
after a thinning process and a
segmentation process so there we go
we have the feature extraction them so
what is next so what is next is called
matching of the different sets so
anytime that you put your fingerprint on
it you will get a different copy a
different photo basically of your
fingerprint you perform a feature
extraction process and therefore you
will get different sets of minutiae
points and as I said before depending on
how much you press down your finger you
will get those minutiae points slightly
moved one side a bit up or a bit down if
you want to but you can also have a very
well
nasty user somehow and then they said I
just want to use this bit of my
fingerprint or I want to rotate that so
the problem is not that easy
imagine algorithm is typically based on
an alignment process of those sets and
they there are many different methods
there local methods and global methods
trying to get that much so in this image
what you see is your regional finger pin
the one that you captured the very first
time was neat and so the one actually
doing the registration ask you to put
the fingerprint perfectly so one thing
that you may actually think are they
gonna be storing directly the picture of
your fingerprint well normally not
normally they just saved those men ocean
points because they don't need to
the whole fingerprint it could be
because there are different techniques
for example of trying to do that
correlation between images but they are
slower and they are not that precise and
they cannot handle well the rotation I
said that differences between the
relative position of those
characteristic points so so what they've
done here is if you like taking a
fingerprint of the fingerprint yes
somehow yes yes so they've got these
exact these points and said right okay
they make that image exactly so next
time we just need to make sure those
points are available
exactly so next time so the algorithm
will use this as the template points and
then whatever you have a different
fingerprint I mean if you look at the
one on the left it's exactly the same
one but you put the finger slightly
rotate and you don't have the full
fingerprint so if you apply again the
same feature extraction process you will
get again a new set of minutiae points
but they do not align perfectly because
they are rotated so feature matching
algorithms they will try to find a local
structure like this one highlighted in
that square and they will try to first
match and see if there are other
minutiae points that are actually
aligned well so Indian if you look at it
so you will see that actually this was
the inclined on the picture to actually
get them so the outcome of the feature
matching process is basically a score
that will be telling you how similar how
likely is that this fingerprint belongs
to this one and then we need to use a
very simple fresh holding approach to
say okay this actually belongs to that
person yes or no all right so this
problem has been solved already based on
feature extraction plus feature matching
there are other techniques as I said but
these two are the classic and the ones
that actually work really well the
sorted so an executable binary the net
effect of slotting that T diagram
against here slightly downwards is to
show you that the see you've written
gets converted into binary and the net
output
from this process it produces out a
program that you probably store in the